[Music]
we're going to let you in on a little
secret
one that's maybe not actually that much
of a secret sometimes
we don't know what we're looking at
we'll find a microbe
that looks familiar but the name of it
eludes us
fortunately we don't need to know the
name of something to show it off
so when these situations arrive we'll go
with a name
that is as specific as we can get like
the ciliate here
that we refer to so specifically as
ciliate but with our new differential
interference
contrast microscope we've been able to
make out all sorts of new details
that we couldn't see before and in some
cases
those new details have helped us
identify
organisms that we could not name before
like if you look closer here you might
be able to make out this little bit of a
crystalline organelle that little tiny
thing is called the organelle of libra
[ __ ]
though it's also known as the watch
glass organelle because
it resembles a watch glass what does it
do
we're not completely sure though it
might be something related to
phototaxis which is how you move toward
or away from
light but what it helps us do is
identify what we are looking at and give
this ciliate the more specific name
of ophiroglina ophiroglina
is a genus of histophagus ciliates
meaning that they feed on
tissue the one we're watching here has
been drawn to this
crustacean like a shark smelling a drop
of blood and water
except it's a microbe drawn to a crack
in its shell
and once it gets inside the ophiroglina
gorges on the tissue inside
so the ophiroglinom seems like it should
be easy enough to find
we just need to keep an eye out for the
watch glass organelle
and other dead organisms but one of the
reasons
it's hard to identify these organisms is
because they do not
always look like this some ciliates have
life cycles
that take them through different shapes
and sizes
and activities and responses it may be
the same organism
but the way that it looks or behaves
changes
ophiroglina's life cycle is made up of
five
established stages as well as a few
additional though more rare
possibilities
the organism starts in its theran stage
taking on an elongated shape as it swims
freely about the microcosmos
it's moving a bit quickly so it might
not be very apparent but at this point
the watch glass organelle
should be visible the third stage
doesn't have food vacuoles yet but it
still seeks
food it'll swim around for about two
days
chasing chemical stimuli and light that
pointed in the general direction of food
but once they settle down into a more
restful state
they begin to fill up with food vacuoles
and
move on to their next stage the
ophiroglina becomes
more opaque as it transitions into its
equivalent of adulthood
the trophon stage at this point the
swimming trophant will still be drawn to
light
perhaps to help hunt down the same dead
tissue these bacteria
are attracted to but as trophant gives
way to protomont
theophyroglina starts to change as well
some will still be attracted to light
but others will be more drawn
to an absence of it this one got stuck
between some glass but
with a little water added to the slide
it's back to moving
then after a few hours of eating the
protomont will begin to slow down
this is the protomance time for change
and so it morphs
into a taumant as a taumant the
ophyroglina avoids
the light as it prepares to reproduce
some
of hyroglina species form a division
cyst
while others create and stay attached to
a sticky
substance instead whatever the venue
the result is the same the taumant
divides
several times to produce anywhere from
four to eight
smaller and rounder termites whose watch
glass organelle has now
disappeared the tomites might form a
chain
that slowly rotates for a few hours
until it separates into therons
bringing the cycle full circle at times
though researchers have observed
deviations from this typical cycle in
some cases the tomant might enter what's
been termed
the migratory stage which is noted for
the largeness of the microbe and
agitated movement before dividing into
tomites or
in rarer cases forming a cyst
it's not clear what conditions would
cause the ophiroglena to enter this
stage just that it's a thing that
happens sometimes
now you might be thinking to yourself
boy we seem to understand all this
really well and honestly the many lives
of the ophiroglina would be its own
business and we would probably
not know all of these things if it
weren't for the fish problem
in 1959 scientists at the eastern fish
disease laboratory at the u.s
bureau of sport fisheries and wildlife
reported that
several of the fish in their aquarium
had died
soon after being infected with a ciliate
the epithelium of the infected fish
had sloughed off and been marked with
white spots
with the right lighting and background
the researchers could even see
a mass of ciliates swarming around the
fish
and their descriptions of the ciliate
you can see the hallmarks
of the ophiroglino life cycle when
active and feeding
the culprit had an elongated shape and
after dining on their course of fish
they would become more rounded and
descend to the bottom of the aquarium
this fish feeding frenzy does not seem
to be
typical of ophiroglina at the very least
this report is the only one we've found
of its kind
though they do have a documented history
of infecting insects
but in the case of the fish infection
the researchers
compared ophiroglina to the obligate
parasite
ichthyotherius multiphilius better known
as ick or just ick disease and fish
the symptoms of both of these infections
are similar and ichthyotherious
is a ciliate whose life cycle has many
steps in common with ophiroglina
including tomites the life cycle of vic
disease is formatted around
the fish the parasite must infect to
survive and as such
the ways of fighting it off are also
oriented around interfering with this
process
of change and growth in the microbe
itself
ophiroglina may not have the same
infectious mandate
but the parallels between their lives
and that of other disease-causing
ciliates
shows why understanding life cycles
isn't just about
how an organism changes over the course
of its own lifetime
it's also about how those changes in
turn
affect the world around them as we all
even the small of us undoubtedly do
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you
as always to these people on the screen
right now if you like this show
these are the folks you should thank
they are our patrons on patreon
they are the reason we can do this at
all and if you would like to join them
you can go to patreon.com journey to
micro where we have a two dollar
and an eight dollar tier and they each
come with their own special perks
and you can learn more about that at
patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss
check out jam and germs on instagram and
if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby